now it's time to meet honor and
celebrate the 1981 world series champion
los angeles dodgers it is a privilege to
be here and celebrate our championship
on the year that the dodgers are
celebrating their 2020 world
championship and go get them again this
guy so the 23 year old josiah gray out
of new rochelle new york made his big
league debut tuesday against the giants
dodgers felt like he showed a lot of
promise had seven strikeouts walked just
one and now he's into the rotation that
is a lead off walk for rymel tapia
brendan rogers the hitter grimel takes
off for second slider
and
safe at second is tapia so another
stolen base for rymel and for the
rockies overall they're tied for fourth
in the national league and stolen bases
that's their 57.
third one gone here's charlie blackman
he gets some swinging that's a big
strikeout for jojo gray two gone in the
first for jojo good for will smith to go
right back with the same pitch that they
called prior to time out with two gone
and a man at third here's trevor's story
and this ball to center field it could
drop and it will trevor story comes
through rymeltapia scores and the
rockies get that first inning run again
after being shut out yesterday that was
a clutch base hit for story cj crone the
first baseman will be the batter story
takes off gray steps off
they've got him hung up
goes into a footwork drill
and he's out as taylor puts
and the rockies run themselves out of
the inning and for john gray it'll be
his 18th start of the year in his last
outing he faced the dodger spilly and he
pitched very well for seven innings it
is chris taylor to lead it off again
he digs it out sends it in the air back
to left top ear to the track a long high
flat ball that gets out home run chris
taylor and it's tied just like that hit
it hard the question was did he get
under it too much but it traveled enough
and it's 1-1
15th home run of the year for him
two-hour walk for smith matt baby comes
up with two guys 1-1 debatey is a ground
ball up the middle right behind second
trevor store he's got it beat smith to
the bag for the force out to end the
first one down in the rockies second
here's elias diaz
oh this ball tagged deep left field
elias diaz has hit it out again
he had one on friday and he puts the
rockies in front on sunday that is home
run number nine for diaz
and his fifth in the month of july
fourth home run allowed by josiah gray
in his first two games in the majors
delivers 2-2 and a fast ball gets
hilliard swinging the fastball usage
today is back around where he's
traditionally been in the minors
story with a two out flare single to
center field back in the first inning
look out
that was a slider up in it
i think it caught whatever on the
shoulder yeah i think you're right
because jerry meals indicated he's to go
to first tell trevor
first
trevor realizes that yet because trevor
really selling it
it didn't hit him because it didn't hit
him
now
that's a strange one dave roberts is
taking a step out and asked jerry meals
to look at it it didn't hit him it hit
the glove of will smith
clearly it did not hit trevor's story
and they'll send story back to the plate
which they have just done that didn't
take very long at all swinging a miss
strike three he got him to chase the
curve ball
and out on strikes his story so that
will load the bases for joshua fuentes
two to one rockies
swing and a miss strike three got him to
chase the high heat and fuentes is out
on strikes two down kicks and fires 0-2
swing into this strike three
as josiah gray pulls his jersey up over
his mouth and yells something into it he
works himself off the hook grey to
pollock with a 1-2 it's part down the
line fair ball into the corner
extra bases for pollock who has extended
his zombie streak to 14 games and the
tying run is in scoring position to give
zach mckinstry an opportunity to tie
this game
a big steal of third with one guard in a
one-run game
surprise steal dodgers don't attempt
olden bases very much aj pollock a
little younger guy much faster but here
playing center field 2-2 on mckinstry
crone coming home out at the plate as
diaz applies the tag on pollock so good
play by cj krohn 37. he quickly thrown
gets it doesn't set his feet just makes
a quick throw and for diaz
as soon as you get the baseball you can
cover up by throwing it so he was
originally given the throwing blade so
two outs for luke raleigh
cold strike three on the outside corner
and john gray rings up luke raleigh one
out for chris taylor who is one for two
with a home run
taylor wakes in a breaking ball hits it
deep to left field taylor putting the
team on his back
tied at two
on two solo shots from ct
carrying the team no matter what
position you put him at and what
position in the batting order he'll
bring the power to the one hole dodgers
have tied it a home run from taylor here
in the fifth two down bring up zach
mckenzie
how street was this hit right center
field
charlie good luck
the ball was caught by blackman
and now as he came together with
hilliard it appears charlie's okay he
took a shot as he and hilliard two big
men collided charlie caught the shoulder
of sam hilliard on his
left thigh and somehow hung onto the
ball first time the dodgers have seen
carlos esteba's this weekend but they
saw him twice last weekend home run in
both games one of them to muncie and one
of them the guy standing in here will
smith
high fly ball left center field he might
have just gotten under it but it keeps
going it kept going that's gone
and the dancers lead
it scraped the clouds
[Applause]
a towering flying ball that is in the
air for a long long time and just like
that the dodgers three outs away from
winning this one joe kelly's turn to
walk on the thin ice that has been the
ninth inning in close games
another one-two pitch little hesitation
and a soft bouncing ball
kelly
does an attempt to throw swinging blunt
base hit to open the ninth possum is
going to come have a look at it yeah
that didn't look good joe's a good
enough athlete to attempt this but when
he gets on his heels there's just only
time to eat it that last step that foot
kind of blows out he blows a tire
scare for the dodgers there the rockies
are barely touching the ball and got the
tying run on second
fastball
rockies now down to their last out kelly
comes home fuentes it's a ground ball to
second for zach mckenstry what does it
they come from behind and win the series
with a 3-2 win on this sunday